what is your interpretation of what's
going on there with Fox and Tucker I
mean I don't know just just from what
I've seen of the reports uh there's a
couple different theories Rupert Murdoch
was threatened personally by Tucker
because his fiance was saying he was a
prophet and then the wedding broke off
and then Tucker gets fired there's uh
the fiance said Tucker is a prophet that
was one of the news reports that came
out that apparently they had a dinner
then Rupert Murdoch's you know fiance
saying like oh he's a he's a prophet
he's a genius oh God then a month later
he's like yeah I'm the prophet yeah I I
think from a business perspective if you
own a brand and then you hire a
personality and the personality is
becoming bigger than the brand any CEO
is going to get rid of that that
person's a threat to their brand that's
that's it you think so
yeah uh I don't know about them I think
I don't know any Murdoch my view would
be that Murdock is saying Fox News is
the company if we're at a point where
people are saying Fox News is doomed
because of one man that man should not
be at this company even if it means it
hurts us in the short term in the long
term Fox News needs to stand on its own
yeah you you have a point there and the
reason why I say I don't think any
because I think Kraft Robert Kraft of
the New England Patriots
for every you know one person that knows
Robert Kraft a thousand people know Tom
Brady and and he was very comfortable
with Tom being the uh the show or
Belichick he kept those guys and Jerry
Buss if you think about Jerry Buss Jerry
Buss was a Playboy you know but you know
in La he was always at the clubs with
the girls and all this stuff he was the
guy who wanted to party with he was a
big real estate guy in 33 years of
owning the Lakers they won 10
championships and he had the magic
bigger than Jerry butts Kobe bigger than
Jerry but Shaq bigger than Jerry Buzz
Pat Riley bigger than Jerry bus I think
there are some that can do it obviously
at this phase I don't know the internal
side of the story here but to have a
girl that you're dating
four or two maybe he's a profit dude
it's a wrap it's done he's awesome he's
two years old so it's but is it
messenger from God you know what Rupert
said I am God yeah if he's a messenger I
am God right anyways so you know we're
gonna see what's gonna happen there with
uh but some of these Republicans or
conservative as much as they about
what's going on and look what Soros is
doing do you see how dark Soros is look
at all these media stop I had to buy him
or be quiet and stop bitching about it
he's going to keep buying them up you
have money as well so you're just using
the money to buy real estate and other
you can also pick up some media
to control your own narrative and
competing and you all you do is 24 7.
you have a look what sorosa's doing look
what this guy's doing we're putting our
money on the line some companies are
putting their monies online so let's go
play ball other companies are sitting
there saying look how dark he is put up
some money you have money you know what
must did musk
took 44 billion and bought Twitter at
the worst possible time at the worst
possible time and what did he call it
I'm running a freaking number of an
organization so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]